بهجوم في الضفة الغربية. بايدن
كان قد وعد تفعيل المادة الخامسة
مخيفة تتجه كوريا الجنوبية الى
الشيخوخة والكوريون مهددون
والدفاع عن كل شبر في ارض
الناتو. وبعد سقوط الصواريخ في
مجموعة قمة العشرين. فهل يحاول
ماكرون التلطف لابن سلمان لحاجة
الى مقعد ولي العهد السعودي محمد
بن سلمان لمصافحته في مقر انعقاد
بولندا. هل ما زال الرئيس
الامريكي عند وعده؟ ام ان كلام
تصافح الرئيس الصيني بيد ويدها
الاخرى تستمر بادارة حربها باردة
اضعاف القدرات الصينية هو اكثر
اهمية بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة
والاوجاع العراقية يعود الى
الواجهة حيث تم قتل شخص واصيب
برلمانية يد في ذلك وثقت لقطات
مصورة لحظة توجه الرئيس الفرنسي
لم يجدها في الجزائر وسيجدها في
السعودية مقتل اسرائيليين اثنين
وسيتم حل الخلافات سلميا حسب
وصفه. ليرد الرئيس الصيني شي
بالانقراض حيث يتجاوز عدد
الوفيات عدد المواليد بحسب دراسة
والتطورات السلطات الجزائرية
تغلق قناة فضائية خاصة لبثها
الصين. فهل سيفعلها البريطانيون
حقا? العراق يصرخ. مسلسل الضربات
الله لا يوفقنا. الله لا يوفقنا
على هالخدمة هذي. الاحداث
مشاهد وصفتها بالمنافية لقيم
المجتمع والدين الاسلامي. بسرعة
في اتصال مع نظيره الايراني.
الضربات الاخيرة التي استهدفت
من الخدمات هناك ليقولها بالحرف.
الله لا يوفقنا على هذه الخدمة.
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني لاحد المستشفيات استاء
صافرات الانذار الى صافرات
الاسعاف. وبعد زيارة رئيس
وذلك حسب ما نقلته وسائل اعلامية
ليقولها وزير الخارجية العراقي
الا يتحول ابدا الى صراع. فهل
يصدق الصينيون ذلك? هنا اصحاب
الامريكي بالقول من الجيد رؤيتك.
ليبدأ حديث مطول بين الزعيمين
بكين بقوله ان بيض ابلغ جي جين
بينغ ان التنافس بين البلدين يجب
بريطانيا يصرح انه لا يستبعد
تسليح تايوان عسكريا لمواجهة
ويشدد على ان تايوان ستبقى الخط
الاحمر الاول في العلاقات بينه
مواقع في اربيل بالعراق تجاوز
سافر على سيادة العراق. ومن مكان
الصيني في بداية قمتهما عالية
المخاطر كما وصفتها صحف عالمية
باسم البنتاجون جون كيربي لا احد
يعلم متى ستنتهي الحرب. وزلنسكي
اكثر من عشرة اخرين لقصف ايراني
على مواقع باقليم كردستان العراق
وبين واشنطن وذلك بحسب وسائل
اعلام صيني. ورئيس وزراء
العيون الضيقة لا يخدعون بسهولة
يا هذا. وبعد اللقاء ها هو لسان
الولايات المتحدة في المقدمة في
قطاع اشباه الموصلات وهو الشيء
مقتنع الان ان الوقت قد حان لوقف
الحرب الروسية المدمرة. التصافح
مع بكين. حيث يتضح من خلال
الاجراءات الامريكية الاخيرة ان
من العمل والتعاون مع الصين. وهي
الحرب التكنولوجية والرقائق
او واشنطن هذا خبر. لكن التقارير
قالت انه كان هناك رسالة نووية
وحده من يختار توقيت التفاوض مع
روسيا وبشروطه. وبين جاء
بيض يتحرك ليقول ان الولايات
المتحدة عادت العالم وستحافظ على
مديري المخابرات لكلا الطرفين
بما لم تؤكد او تنفي اي من موسكو
في بالي باندونيسيا. ابتسم بايدن
بينما استقبل شيا الزعيم
لوقف الحرب الروسية في بلاده
بموجب خطة سلام اقترحها وقال انا
وهي المرة الاولى التي يلتقي
فيها بايدن وشيك قادة. واشنطن
الالكترونية التي تهدف الى زعزعة
صناعة الالكترونيات الصينية ووضع
ويقول لا يحق لاحد سلب روسيا حق
بالمشاركة بالمنصات الدولية. ومن
فقد بدأت محادثات بين الوفدين
الروسي والامريكي في انقرة بحضور
الزلنسكي ليتحدث عن خطة لانهاء
الحرب مؤكدا بان الوقت قد حان
التزاماتها. مشددا على انه لن
تكون هناك محاولة لاجتياح تايوان
الذي تخلف عنه امريكا منذ فترة.
بينما يحاول البيت الابيض تخدير
الماكر بين بكين وواشنطن. القوة
تفرض نفسها والعدو ياتي بقدميه
الى عدوه. هنا يصل الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ويصافح نظيره
التراشق بالتصريحات والتهديدات
الى الطاولة التركية التي جمعت
وملفات خطيرة بين امريكا وروسيا
على الطاولة دون التطرق الى حرب
على سرقة روسيا وموسكو ستتعامل
معه كوثيقة غير ملزمة فكيف سترد
الاعداء معا وفي طاولة واحدة
وفقا لما كشفته صحيفة الروسية
الامم المتحدة يا ترى? فوزير
الخارجية الصيني يقف مع روسيا
اوكرانيا. فهل دعت واشنطن كييف
لتسترضي موسكو ليعلن المتحدث
المتحدة بشأن دفع تعويضات
لاوكرانيا يهدف لاضفاء طابع رسمي
الخاصة بسبب رفض كييف اجراء
مفاوضات. بينما ردت الرئاسة
الكريملين ديمتري بسكوف ويقول ان
قرار الجمعية العامة للامم
الاوكرانية الحرب مستمرة بسبب
تلاعب روسيا وعدم رغبتها وقف
القتل. فمن سيوقف الحرب اذا بعد
هذا كل ليخرج المتحدث باسم
الى اوكرانيا فقد كشفت وسائل
اعلام روسية ان الجيش الروسي وضع
بين الناتو وروسيا كما تقول بعض
التقارير ومجلس الدوما يقول ان
بينما رئيس لتوانيا يصرح نقف في
تضامن كامل مع بولندا وعلينا
لضمان اصابة اي اهداف ومنشآت
تابعة للقوات الاوكرانية بدقة
تحقيق الاهداف المحددة في
اوكرانيا عبر العملية العسكرية
كبيرة بينما يتحدث الروس عن
مشروع الرجل الحديدي ببدلات
اصدر بوتين مرسوما جديدا يفتح
باب الجيش الروسي على مصراعيه
الملصقات فورا حتى لا يتم
تفسيرها على انها شعارات نازية
الدفاع الروسية نفت استهداف اراض
خارج اوكرانيا وقالت ان التقارير
تواجه برلين بذلك عدو النازيين
الاول روسيا. هناك اعلنت روسيا
ابحثوا لكم عن خصم اخر. فهل هي
صواريخ روسية ام ان الاوكران
الدفاع عن كل شبر من مرض الناتو.
فيما قال رئيس الوزراء التشيكي
اسقطوا صواريخ روسية خارج
اراضيهم لبث الفتنة واشعال حرب
من المتوقع ان تكون القوات
الاوكرانية متورطة في حادثة
بالقوات العسكرية الروسية وذلك
بحسب المرسوم الذي اطلقه بوتين.
في حين اكد سونا تنسيق لندن مع
حلفائها الدوليين بما في ذلك
لكل العالم. فمن يقيم في روسيا
من اي جنسية يحق له الالتحاق
بولندا الاعتماد على فرنسا في
دعم التحقيقات الجارية وكل يغني
خريطة رقمية لاوكرانيا تساعد في
تدريب مشغلي المسيرات الانتحارية
الناتو ليصل الصدى الى الرئيس
الفرنسي ماكرون ويصرح ان بامكان
صواريخ بولندا. هنا الاحداث
تشتعل اكثر فاكثر. ومن بولندا
على ليلاه. فمن سيؤدي دور المحقق
كونان ليكشف الفاعليات. ترى
شعار النازية? هناك طالبت
القيادة الالمانية بنزع تلك
فمن سيستجيب لهذا المرسوم ليعلن
الجيش الالماني عن خطأ بوضع
حديدية يتم تصنيعها من درع مركبة
عسكرية كما تقول موسكو. خلال ذلك
عناصر من قواته ملصقات من زيهم
الموحد الجديد الذي يرمز الى
والمساعدة لبولندا في التحقيق
حول سقوط الصواريخ على اراضيها
بولندا. فال ينفذ بايدن وعده
بتفعيل المادة الخامسة لكن
نحن نقف بثبات الى جانب بولندا
حليفنا في الاتحاد الاوروبي
التي تتحدث عن ذلك هي استفزاز
متعمد وكانهم يقولون للغرب
والناتو. ليخرج سيناتور امريكي
متسائلا روسيا قصفت عضو الناتو
عبر الخط الساخن بين الرئيس
الامريكي وامين عام حلف الناتو
لكننا نجري محادثات مع الحلفاء
بشأن الحادثة ولا يمكننا حاليا
تقديم شرح مفصل حول حادثة
الاعداء حسب وصفهم ليصل الامر
نفس الخط رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسوناك يعرض تقديم الدعم
لاجتماع عاجل للجنة الامن القومي
والدفاع ومستشار الرئيس
الى وزير الدفاع ويعلن عن جاهزية
وحداتهم القتالية وقواتهم
حول الهجوم في بولندا. الاوضاع
تزداد سوءا لدى الناتو فهل سيدخل
بمنتهى الجدية مع التقارير عن
سقوط صاروخين روسيين في بولندا.
التطورات الاخيرة. هناك استدعت
بولندا السفير الروسي والهدف
شرقي بولندا واعلان مسؤول
استخباراتي امريكي عن مقتل شخصين
جراء صواريخ روسية في بولندا.
رئيس الوزراء البولندي يدعو
في حرب ضد روسيا ام سيهتز رصيد
ثقة الحلفاء بتجاهل القضية. وعلى
تأكيد صحة التقارير. والبيت
الابيض يصرح وجود محادثات هاتفية
المسلحة لمتابعة الموقف ولضمان
الامن. ليصرح البنتاجون نتعامل
الاوكراني يؤكد ان قوات الناتو
ستكون في حالة تأهب قصوى بعد
قيادة العالم في حين تشتعل الحرب
الباردة بين واشنطن وبكين فما
لا يوفقنا قتلى وجرحى في
الولايات المتحدة والجزائر تتخذ
الناتو وروسيا? فبعد سقوط
صاروخين طائشين في بلدة بيرزيودف
عالمية ثالثة ولا يبتعد فهل حان
وقت المواجهة المباشرة بين
هذا الاجراء احتراما للدين
الاسلامي. ولهذا السبب سكان
الروسية تفقد اعصابها. شيئا
فشيئا يقترب العالم من حرب
كوريا في طريقهم للانقراض فماذا
فعل كيم هذه المرة? الصواريخ
الذي يجري? العراق يتلقى الضربات
من جديد ورئيس وزرائه يرد. الله
والامريكان على طاولة اردوغان.
فما القصة يكشف عن خطة لانهاء
يتأهب والمانيا تتراجع عن خطأها
قبل ان تغضب بوتين والروس
تتساقط صواريخ روسيا في بولندا
الجميع يهرب الى الملاجئ والناتو
وهذه الاسلحة سننهي الحرب باسرع
وقت. هكذا اعلنت روسيا بينما
الحرب وبعد لقائه بالرئيس الصيني
يصرح عادت الولايات المتحدة الى
الليل يمحوه